three two  [Music]  wait there's a food processor hey what's  up everyone my name is tui and welcome  to a whole new season of making it big  the show where i turn your favorite  foods giant what oh my god this is so  big oh i'm a chef and content creator i  share really easy to follow recipes most  of them being vietnamese recipes because  i'm  this is so much flour this next step is  going to be insane everything that i do  basically revolves around food it's  definitely safe to say that i love food  and i love my culture i'm really proud  of myself  i'm taking some of my favorite recipes  whether it's my own or classics that i  grew up eating and making it big this is  going to be  huge i knew it was going to be big but  this is big make sure to subscribe and  follow me for updates because you don't  want to miss out on this season